[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le 7-8 journal de tv
60,18 bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine d'information locale tout de
suite les titres de ce lundi 18 février
la formation est axée sur la physique
chimie et les sciences de l'ingénieur la
classe préparatoire du lycée descartes à
montigny le bretonneux à dix ans
l'établissement ni sur la proximité le
partenariat avec l'ue vs q reportage
lors d'un cours
l'inquiétude des pompiers des yvelines
il ferait face à un manque d'effectifs
alors que le nombre d'interventions
augmente selon eux il manquerait environ
130 postes pour assurer la protection de
la population et nous recevons le
syndicat autonome du sdiss des yvelines
et à la fin de cette édition retour sur
cet événement à cerner la ville un show
de strass et de paillettes en faveur du
petit nathan pour la première fois la
traditionnelle soirée s'est prolongée en
week end inattendue autres invités de
cette édition josé lucas président de la
rs nous parlerons de la restitution de
ce colloque des logements autonomes des
logements autonomes comme réponse à
l'exclusion des personnes handicapées à
c'est tout à l'heure dans ce journal en
2008 à montigny le bretonneux le lycée
descartes ouvrait sa à classes
préparatoires une collaboration lycées
et universités qui était une première en
france à l'époque et qui continue de
faire accéder aujourd'hui des étudiants
aux prestigieuses écoles d'ingénieurs
chaque année pour ses 10 ans plongée au
sein de cette prépa avec marylène yapi
chiffres ce matin là au lycée descartes
les étudiants de première année de
classe préparatoire scientifique suivre
un cours de physique mécanique sur les
solides et en rotation autour d'un axe
fixe
imaginez par exemple de forme
cette classe préparatoire fête cette
année ses 10 ans intégrer directement
après le bac elle permet aux étudiants
de se former durant deux ans et obtenir
ensuite les concours d'entrée aux écoles
d'ingénieurs
j'aime bien le rythme mais tout va bien
être toujours boosté par les profs
peut-être toujours aller au delà du
mythe a beau temps de les former ou
passer des études particularité de la
classe prépa pcs et du lycée descartes
son partenariat direct avec l'université
en 2008 elle était la première à
fonctionner ainsi
cette décennie marque son efficacité une
journée par semaine nos étudiants vont à
l'ufr des sciences à versailles est en
fait ils bénéficient d du matériel des
techniciens de l'université qui vont les
aider donc pour les tp l'avantagé qu'on
a toujours du matériel en très grand
nombre d'exemplaires alors que leur
lycée standard va avoir pour du matériel
un petit peu cher un ou deux exemplaires
les étudiants viennent principalement du
bassin saint quentinois
nul besoin de se rendre dans les plus
prestigieux lycée parisien pour viser
les meilleures écoles d'autant plus que
peu nombreux par promotion il bénéficie
d'un vrai suivi personnalisé de la part
de leurs professeurs le matin j'ai un
vélo par exemple et donc ça ça un
facteur à prendre en compte je pense
pour l'épanouissement
vraiment on connaît nos élèves nos
étudiants parker qu'on a l'habitude de
dire une classe un professeur donc cette
année vous avez vu les 25 et qui était
là et sur le jeu n'est que 25 élèves
devant moi toute l'année dans dix ans la
classe préparatoire du lycée descartes a
pu faire rentrer ses étudiants dans les
plus grandes écoles d'ingénieurs seuls
15 % d'entre eux se sont orientés
ils l'ont baptisé acteurs de la
mobilisation samedi près de 300 gilet
jaune se sont réunis à montrent la jolie
venus pour la plupart de rouen et de
leurs pas de grands débordements à noter
est les manifestant es tu étais rires
ont été privés de manifester en centre
ville par arrêté préfectoral dans les
messages affichés la revendication du
riq notamment certaines personnes ont
mimé l'arrestation des 151 jeunes en
décembre en marge du rassemblement
lycéen dans la ville ne tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé pompiers inquiets face
au manque d'effectifs dans le
département pour en parler deux invités
autour de cette table pierre ruiz dupont
et jérémy courtel bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir le respectivement président et
vice-président du syndicat autonome
dix des yvelines alors la semaine
dernière une cinquantaine de personnes
de pompiers a profité du conseil
d'administration de ce service
d'incendié et de secours des a's
yvelines pour alerter sur la situation
quel est le constat aujourd'hui que vous
faites il manque des postes de pompiers
dans les yvelines
merci de donner la parole je vais
revenir sur le mouvement du 12
enfin quand c'est un mouvement
intersyndical géré par une
intersyndicale qui représente l'unsa et
la cgt ensuite le syndicat national des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels snspp et
le syndicat autonome des yvelines donc
notre organisation affiliée à la
fédération autonome des sapeurs pompiers
disent d'accord
la précision est fait du coup sûr le
constat aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il
manque des postes il manque des postes
les chiffres sont assez assez parlants
sont assez parlants je vous propose de
donner la parole à jérémy il va vous
faire un constat sur ces chiffres là et
vous allez voir s'ils sont assez
alarmants dans quel est le constat
monsieur courtes elles ont atteint
recherche de travail au fond au vu des
derniers conseils d'administration on
est remonté jusqu'à 2009 et de 2009 à
aujourd'hui on a une perte au niveau de
l'effectif budgétés qui est de 100
sapeurs pompiers professionnels pour
agir sur le terrain on a également au
niveau de ses effectifs budgété l'amant
qu'avec l'effectif réel qui est
d'environ trente pompiers c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui en demande 130 sapeurs
pompiers sur le terrain pour venir
renforcer les effectifs en poste
donc il y manque il manque ces postes
sur les yvelines et parallèlement il ya
un autre constat c'est que le nombre
d'interventions augmente sur le
département
tout à fait donc on a une augmentation
des interventions sur les deux dernières
années qu'à augmenter à peu près de 24
mille interventions donc qu'elle en soit
une augmentation assez notable donc à
peu près de 21% de ce qu'on pouvait
faire auparavant
et comment expliquer cette augmentation
la tendance peut-être a appelé les
pompiers plus souvent pour des urgences
qui nécessitent pas forcément une
intervention des pompiers s'il ya une
vraie une vraie interrogation
aujourd'hui sur la le ressenti de la
population envers une demande de service
on est bien là dans une problématique
entre le sapeur pompier qui lui est
formé à faire de l'urgence et les
citoyens qui appellent pour un besoin
énorme en service on est presque à voir
leur sentiment qu'on est là pour vendre
un service et c'est là où il ya une
problématique entre cet engagement de
plus en plus important
avant les chiffres assez impressionnant
et ses effectifs qui sont pas en
relation avec cette augmentation est
quelle est la réalité du métier
aujourd'hui pour les plus jeunes c'est
un métier qui a tendance à faire rêver
celui de pompier
est ce que la réalité loin du rêve en
tout cas quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui la situation professionnelle
elle est particulière il ya un déficit
de recrutement au sein des sapeurs
pompiers professionnels
d'une part par le lot des autres métiers
d'actions qui sont aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus thématiques et donc ça intéresse
beaucoup plus les jeunes et le sapeur
pompier aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on a
des difficultés à recruter
c'est vrai qu'on a des effets car il ya
une résonance sur les chiffres peut-être
que les images que l'on voit aujourd'hui
sur les agresser les accusations de sa
demande mon pied où ça donne peut-être
un point mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
toujours cette cette flamme à
l'intérieur de chaque sapeur pompier qui
lui donne envie de revenir et le jeune
le métier vraiment à changer comme vous
dites il ya beaucoup plus d'assistance
de soins et l'urgence est ponctuel et
vous allez dd violence des agressions ça
c'est un phénomène qui augmente ses
essais dernière dernières années ces
agressions de pompiers elle augmente
exactement que les chiffres sans parlent
d'eux mêmes on est à 30 % est me
semble-t-il les documents qui on peut
les expliquer de différentes façons
aujourd'hui le sapeur pompier intervient
c'est le premier maillon de millas
social entre l'état et le citoyen dès
qu'on a besoin d'urgence qu'on appelle
les sapeurs pompiers dès qu'on a une
question on appelle les sapeurs pompiers
donc ça crée une différence entre
l'engagement pour lequel on en rentre
pour faire de l'urgence et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui à faire beaucoup
plus de services et d'assistanat aux
personnes et gérer microtel vous le
disiez tout à l'heure il faudrait
aujourd'hui 130 postes
on a posé la situation le contexte 130
postes aujourd'hui serait nécessaire
pour les pompiers des yvelines 130 potes
me permettra de revenir comme on l'était
avant donc dès lors de 2009 jusqu'à 2016
ou non intervention n'augmentait pas du
moins stagné y avait quelques
fluctuations qui en était fait mais sans
pour autant que ce soit notable
aujourd'hui c'est c'est quelque chose de
concret l'augmentation est là les
chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes et
l'augmentation est nécessaire et le dise
pour information qu'on n'a pas précisé
dans cet entretien c'est un
établissement public autonome dans son
conseil d'administration plusieurs
partenaires dont le conseil
départemental des yvelines écoutez la
réaction sur votre situation du
président du département pierre bédier
je fais toute confiance aux dirigeants
du sdiss donc aussi bien en alexandre
joly qui préside son conseil
d'administration que l'ensemble de
l'état major du sdiss pour faire que
l'émission puis se continue à être
remplie avec les personnels actuels au
service de tous les yvelinois ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que j'entends
les demandes de personnel nouveau je les
entends partout mais avec quel argent
il ya un moment où l'argent vient à
manquer les déficits s'accumulent donc
nous devons essayer c'est en tout cas
comme ça que le département des yvelines
pratique pour lui même nous devons
essayer toujours de faire mieux ou de
faire a minima aussi bien avec moins de
moyens parce que c'est l'époque qui veut
ça
pierre bédier ledit largement qu'il faut
faire donc des économies qu'est ce que
vous répondez super tirer une analyse
financière de la situation encore une
fois nous on est une partenaire social
et on alerte sur les moyens les
personnels il parle de mission remplie
avec le même personnel donc si on se
base sur les années précédentes
l'émission ont augmenté on est encore
sur un personnel inférieur à ce qu'on
avait besoin
donc oui on pourrait faire ce qui nous
le dit et on le souhaite et pour ça il
faut vraiment qu'on embauche il faut il
nous faudra ça sera le mot de la fin
c'est c'est nécessaire pour assurer une
bonne protection de la population
mais plus que ça il faut avoir une
protection de la population mais faut
également que le pompiers s'entraînent
il faut qu'il s'entraîne physiquement
techniquement mentalement et ça pour
cela il faut des gars ensemble de
secours pour que les autres puissent
aller aux interventions pendant les
autres s'entraînent aujourd'hui on est à
flux tendus on ne fait que sortir sortir
et vous vouliez donner j'ai un micro tel
le nombre d'interventions par jour c'est
ça tout à fait est intervenu au niveau
des interventions de 2009 et tout au
long jusqu'à 2016 et aujourd'hui on a
cinquante neuf interventions en plus par
jour sur le département
d'où votre demande de d'avoir des postes
supplémentaires pierre russe du point et
jérémy courte et le merci d'être passé
sur ce plateau et je rappelle que vous
êtes président et vice-président du
syndicat autonome du s10 des yvelines
autre inquiétude celle des 52 salariés
de pizza del arte est implantée à vélizy
2 plusieurs d'entre eux se sont
enchaînées devant l'entrée du restaurant
sam
ils dénoncent la fermeture de
l'enseignent ouverte en 1972 dans le
centre commercial el malgré un chiffre
d'affaires de 4 millions d'euros annuels
l'établissement en baissera le rideau le
22 mars prochain en raison d'une
résiliation du bail les employés
demandent un plan social digne et
prévoit d'autres actions
une première visite avait eu lieu il y a
un an les élus du conseil régional
othman natrue et geoffroy didier s'était
rendu au square ifart j'attrape pour
constater certaines situations
d'insalubrité des logements plus de 4000
seraient concernés dans la ville un an
plus tard les deux conseillers régionaux
sont revenus sur place pour constater l
évolution des dossiers notamment celui
d'une famille qui a pu être relogée un
déplacement également à la résidence
paul verlaine le conseil régional qui
s'est engagé à faire pression sur les
bailleurs qui ne respectent pas leurs
obligations les propos sont recueillis
par mélanie poké aujourd'hui nous
voulons à la fois constater que cette
famille a été relogée ce qui est une
victoire et un succès mais aussi nous
assurer que dans d'autres situations
nous allons visiter d'autres situations
difficiles il y a encore la nécessité
que le bailleur respecte ses obligations
et on a pour cela des associations
extrêmement mobilisés qu'il faut qu'on
sociale parce que la loi c'est dans les
deux sens il ya les droits il ya les
devra y compris pour les bailleurs
sociaux
c'est l'institution régionale dont je
suis l'un des vice-présidents qui
financent cofinance du logement social
et lorsqu'on est un bailleur social on a
des droits et des devoirs mais les
locataires ont aussi des droits
notamment celui de vivre dans la dignité
et ce à quoi j'avais assisté n'était pas
acceptable c'est la seule commune d'île
de france avec un maire du rassemblement
national mantes-la-ville alors qu'une
liste est envisagée entre les différents
groupes d'opposition en vue des
municipales 2020 une première
candidature est lancé officiellement un
collectif baptisé un new man devillois
les détails dans ce reportage de nicolas
landry la campagne municipale et élancé
à mantes la ville comme une importante
pour le rassemblement national le parti
à la tête de la municipalité avec son
maire cyril note face à cette majorité
un collectif citoyen baptisé nous
mentent lillois s'est constitué avec une
sensibilité de gauche
depuis 2014 et jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a
fait le constat douloureux d'une gestion
municipale de mantes-la-ville
catastrophique sur tous les sujets
toutes les prérogatives de la ville par
sa majorité actuelle front national et
face à ce constat là et face à cette
urgence et face aux autres urgences qui
sont les urgences environnementales d
urgence sociale urgence démocratique
on a décidé nous habitants de mantes la
ville de prendre les devants et avec nos
voisins avec les habitants de la ville
de construire la ville de demain et pour
construire leur projet municipal
l'association souhaite faire participer
les citoyens pendant ces douze mois
utilisée chaque seconde pour solliciter
et faire participer la plus nos voisins
pour pour construire à la fois les
priorités et par rapport à ses priorités
la dégager les solutions qui sont
adaptées au contexte de mantes la ville
parallèlement à cela un front
républicain pourrait voir le jour à
travers une union entre les républicains
et le parti socialiste
quant à cyril note il n'a pas encore
officialisé sa candidature des logements
autonomes comme réponse à l'exclusion
des personnes en situation de handicap
le thème d'un colloque qui était proposé
la semaine dernière en salle du conseil
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines la restitution d'une enquête
menée par les étudiants de l'ue vs qu
ele that de la marsa vin pour en parler
josé lucas bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
président de l'association insertion
éducation soins ligne e s qui gère cet
esat de la marsa vin qui est située à
trappes c'est établissement et service
d'aidé par le travail a donc mené cette
enquête avec les étudiants un master 2
de l'université versailles saint quentin
master de politique sociale
territorialisée c'est là toute
l'originalité de cette démarche
d'originalité pour nous ça a été une
opportunité on a la chance d'avoir sur
saint quentin il a une super université
très dynamique
on a des relations avec matière et liker
professeurs sur l'université et donc on
a profité de cette opportunité pour
faire bien
une étude d'une analyse qu'on aurait pas
eu les moyens de faire autrement et donc
on a bénéficié un travail absolument
superbe qui a été fait par l'équipe
d'étudiants et pour nous c'était un gros
gros plus sur un sujet qui nous
touche de très près cette enquête
justement aborde les difficultés
rencontrées par les personnes en
situation de handicap alors pour accéder
ou pour se maintenir dans un logement
autonome
quels sont les objectifs qu'elles aient
été les objectifs de cette enquête
pourquoi la la faire cette enquête les
objectifs étaient déjà doit d'avoir un
constat de pouvoir faire un peu une
analyse de voir un petit peu où on est
sur le territoire à sortir dehors de 50
des yvelines en fin de groupe
globalement mais plutôt saint quentin et
voir un peu ce qui existait où on en
était ce qu'on pouvait faire
ensuite pour mettre en place d'autres
d'autres techniques d'autres projets et
pour un petit peu comment on pouvait
faire travailler les gens ensemble le
groupe problèmes qu'on retrouve dans le
logement et ça c'est un petit plus qui
est ressorti l'analyse c'est qu'il
existe plein de choses on a eu quand
même lors de ce colloque qu'on avait des
interlocuteurs donc de la préfecture de
l'état on avait le département bien
évidemment qu'ils étaient là on avait 50
et en yvelines qui était présent on
avait un certain nombre d'élus je pense
à attraper guyancourt il y avait
vraiment énorme plaisir il ya énormément
de monde et il y avait aussi toutes les
associations plus vraiment de lui
ensemble d'aidés des acteurs de ce
secteur multiples acteurs qui ont
peut-être du mal à travailler ensemble
il ya une amende choses qui sont faites
en fait après en concret sur le terrain
on les voit pas trop donc on a
énormément de mal à trouver des
logements pour nos travailleurs auront à
145 travailleurs ale that on leur offre
le travail le travail
jaipur un point pour un handicapé en
forme et kpn personnes en situation de
handicap
le plus important c'est le travail pour
l'insertion c'est le travail et ses deux
logements
si on fait juste un constat sur saint
quentin en yvelines ce que vous l'avez
dit ça ça concerne toutes les énigmes et
sur 50 ans est ce qu'il ya une réelle
volonté au départ en tout cas de
favoriser l'accès ce maintien des
personnes en situation de handicap au
logement de je pense qu'il y aurait bien
un véritable lien véritable souhait le
saint quentin en yvelines et des
yvelines en fait un globalement du
département le problème c'est que
derrière il faut arriver à mettre tout
ça en musique
arriver à faire travailler les gens
semblent aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ce
qu'on s'aperçoit qu'en fait il ya plein
de choses qui existent on n'arrive pas à
les mettre
on n'arrive pas à travailler à faire
travailler les gens ensemble par exemple
nous au niveau 2 les attaques nouvel
associé on n'avait pas été du tout
impliqué dans des dents des tas de
projets qui existent
c'était l'occasion et l'opportunité pour
nous de pouvoir mettre en pratique tout
cela je pense que là vraiment on a fait
un grand grand pas bien évidemment n'a
pas on n'a pas créé cinq cent mille
logements il faut être très clair
mais c'est vrai que le pas il a été fait
je pense
maintenant il faut absolument continuer
pour arriver à développer à tout ce qui
peut se faire dans les fraises que a été
mis également peut-être la lourdeur
administrative des démarches et alors
nous on a une population on fait surtout
nous est essentiellement d'aider des
personnes en situation de handicap
psychique intellectuelle cognitifs et
donc le gros problème c'est il ya aussi
la toute la partie administrative
on a en plus c'est une population qui
n'est pas reconnu comme le handicapé
moteur ça c'est moins visible
donc en fait le problème c'est qu'il
doit se dérouler dans le droit commun il
se trouve dans la même situation qu'un
cas chercheurs de logements autres et
c'est vrai que c'est pas simple parce
qu'il ya quand même une lourdeur
administrative dans les documents
remplir pour demander à l'agent sociales
qui sont vraiment énormes
donc on les aide mais c'est vrai que
tout ça c'est des choses qui doit être
vu c'est plein de choses qui ont été
discutés qui vont apporter je pense un
petit plus donc une fois ce constat
établi
justement quelles préconisations ont été
les préconisations à une préconisation
ses new skies que ce qu'on souhaiterait
déjà un petit peu en dehors des
préconisations c'est qu'on puisse avoir
des logements qu'ils soient des
logements intermédiaires pour pouvoir
loger ce type de population pour un
point à temps le temps de les habituer
un petit peu à la vie à la vie dans le
monde ordinaire
ils ont ils en sont capables le problème
c'est que ça passe par une formation par
un peu de temps de travail et je pense
que là c'est le premier pas ensuite il
ya des points qui ont été les points les
plus importants c'est le fait qu'on
arrive si avoir à travailler tous
ensemble sur un colloque qui a duré deux
heures tout le monde a eu la parole tout
mou n'a plus donné ses idées tout le
monde a annoncé ce qu'il faisait parce
qu'il existe plein de choses et on s'est
tous mis d'accord pour pouvoir se revoir
notamment à l'instar de la préfecture
des yvelines pour qu'ils aient vraiment
qu'on soit invité notamment en tant
qu'association quand je suis invité un
petit peu dans ce travail et je pense
que là tout le monde est partie prenante
et tout le monde est d'accord pour le
faire et je pense qu'on va vraiment
avancer le problème c'est qu'on part de
très loin quand même hein c'est pas
simple mais je pense qu'il ya vraiment
de quoi vraiment le travail en commun
c'est la grosse préconisations gamin il
n'y a pas de réussite possible et que
fait-on maintenant du coup on va on va
leur échapper aux prochaines réunions
donc avec la préfecture on va être
invité donc c'est vrai que là on va
prend même à pouvoir travailler sur des
sujets concrets voir un petit peu ce
qu'on peut faire et je pense que c'était
vraiment une très bonne chose de touche
se voir tous en parler voir nos
problèmes et pouvoir les mettre sur la
table et pouvoir essayer d'avancer et
pour plus d'informations sur
l'association lei us je vous invite à
vous rendre sur site internet qui s'est
affichée durant cet entretien merci et
josé lucas a laissé à brasser sur ce
plateau présidente de la rs
l'association insertion éducation
- à aubergenville le campus des écoles
des éco-activités enrichit son offre de
formation vendredi dernier une nouvelle
plate forme destinée aux métiers du
ferroviaire a été inaugurée 300
apprentis seront formés jusqu'en 2021
reportage daury lyon c'est un projet
unique en france
léa les écoles des éco-activités possède
désormais un plateau technique
ferroviaire sur le campus
d'aubergenville 600 mètres de voies vont
permettre de former les élèves aux
métiers de la signalisation de la
caténaire ou encore de la voie ferrée il
apporte des compléments aux informations
et des supports aux formations des
jeunes et des moins jeunes puisque nous
allons commencer par la formation
continue pour le plateau ferroviaire qui
sont absolument indispensables pour que
lorsque les personnes rentrer dans la
vie active ou reviennent à la vie qu'ils
soient parfaitement opérationnels avec
ses quatre campus en ile-de-france les
écoles des éco-activités accueil 1700
étudiants pour des formations qui vont
du ceap et au master 2 particularité ces
formations sont conçus avec les
entreprises
il faut former des jeunes qui peuvent
entretenir réparer les voies de chemin
de fer il se trouve qu'il ya un très
grand besoin en ile de france à raison
du grand paris on va construire 200 km
de voies ferrées du port et on va
doubler le métro parisien
donc il ya besoin important
[Musique]
un projet de 2,8 millions d'euros
financés à 40 % par le département des
yvelines et son agent l'insertion
activités ici vous avez un beau cercle
vertueux de l'investissement public qui
va générer de l'emploi
cet emploi va permettre de l'insertion
et tout ça parce qu'il y aura eu
formation
c'est le cercle parfait jusqu'en 2021
sur le site d'aubergenville près de 300
apprentis et stagiaires seront formés
aux métiers du ferroviaire
[Musique]
le lundi forcément le jour de la
chronique sport de michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir mon seul regret les
week-ends qui se suivent mais ne se
ressemblent pas du vent la semaine
dernière un très beau temps ce week-end
on va commencer cette rubrique avec du
rugby le championnat de fédérale 2
directions plaisir les plaisirs wa
peuvent jubiler le prc a fait tomber ce
dimanche le deuxième du classement
drancy à domicile les joies décuplée par
le scénario du match je vais vous faire
un résumé rapide de cette rencontre en
première période plaisir n'arrive pas à
prendre la mesure de son adversaire se
fait corriger 17 à 3 avec deux essais
concédés et forcément les murs ont dû
trembler dans les vestiaires
effectivement on en prend 15 7 points
mais on sait surtout dû à nos erreurs on
les met dedans avec nos erreurs et fasse
une belle équipe comme ça c'est sûr
qu'on est sanctionné tout de suite il a
manqué un peu de maîtrise sur cette
première mi temps
pour espérer faire mieux pas première
mi-temps on la perd largement et on se
remet en question dans les serres barbe
est le capitaine
les entraîneurs et ça nous aurait amené
un coup de un coup de jus pour finir ce
match en deuxième période les joueurs
plaisir war reviennent sur la pelouse
métamorphosé y arrive à inscrire trois
essais en 40 minutes de jeu mais drancy
a la balle de match vous le voyez à
l'écran dans les toutes dernières
secondes pour l'emporter
vous avez vu oui malheureusement il
laisse échapper la balle et ils
n'arrivent pas à conclure plaisir
l'emportent sur le fil en voilà on
revoit l'action au ralenti luneau voilà
le plaisir l'emportent sur le fil 24 à
23 2 dernières pénalités et notamment la
dernière bon on s'en sort très bien avec
le poteau le 15 qui récupère qui fait en
avant dans l'en but
comment on pouvait pas avoir meilleur
scénario effectivement en terme de
réussite
après j'ai envie de vous dire par
rapport à tous les matches qu'on a eu
avant c'est un peu de justice
qu'aujourd'hui ça tombe pour nous avec
cette victoire plaisir pointe à la 9e
place du championnat de fédérale 2 avec
7 points d'avancé sur le premier
relégable paris université club
avec cet exploit le staff plaisir roy
espère désormais pouvoir terminer la
saison en milieu de tableau du rugby
toujours pour continuer un autre club
saint quentinois mutuelle dans
championnat de division honneur cette
fois ci le sky rugby n'a pas pu résister
aux assauts de l'entente maisons
laffitte saint jean dans les poissy
leader du championnat les saint
quentinois se sont lourdement inclinés
41 6 ce dimanche après midi
au classement le sky reste 7e du
championnat avec un bilan de 5 victoires
1 nul et huit défaites depuis le début
de la saison et du football pour
terminer le championnat de régionale 3
trap a réussi une très belle prestation
ce week-end les trappistes se sont
imposés sur le score fleuve de 3 buts à
0 face à franconville une équipe de bas
de classement avec sept victoires trappe
pro prend la place de leader à boulogne
billancourt après 13 journées disputées
prochain match pour les trappistes ce
dimanche 24 février sur le terrain doni
un autre mal classé
suivra la suit avec attention merci
michael on vous retrouve dans votre
émission de 7,8 sport pour un résumé de
l'actualité sportive du week end
l'actualité aussi sportives à venir
mais avant de se quitter un événement
festif et surtout solidaire pour la
première fois la soirée inattendue est
devenu week-end dîner et goûter
spectacle au profit de l'association
elle n'attend le combat d'un ange nous
étions sur place samedi soir
[Musique]
le rendez vous est pris depuis trois ans
désormais au cabaret du bout des prix à
cerner la ville salle comble pour ce
dîner spectacle caritatif
un show au profit de l'association on
attend le combat d'un ange
les fonds récoltés vont servir à
financer les thérapies suivi à barcelone
par nathan un petit garçon de 11 ans
atteint d'une maladie neurologique rare
c'est pour passe aussi un bon moment
tous ensemble et puis voilà c est déjà
ça mais c'est aussi pour récolter des
fonds pour pour nathan pour pouvoir
financer les acteurs apathiques en
espagne voilà c'est ça se déroule en
espagne ces quatre heures des
stimulations par jour et dont trois
semaines ça coûte 5000 euros donc une
soirée comme celle ci finance quasiment
un stage
cette année de nouveaux artistes se sont
joints à la bande de nathan déjà très
nombreuses
[Applaudissements]
des chanteurs danseurs magicien
humoriste tous réunis pour cette soirée
qui s'est achevée tard dans la nuit ça
m'a beaucoup touché j'ai rencontré
l'enfant et ses parents vraiment des
gens géniaux très courageux et puis en
ce qui concerne la soirée super public
pour montrer aux gens que que ce cabaret
il n'est pas fait que pour faire du
spectacle il est là aussi pour la
solidarité donc on en profite
je trouve qu'il ya une belle énergie
autour de nathan et il faut garder cette
même énergie
donc moi chaque année je reviens avec
plaisir et je continuerai à le faire et
pour la première fois la soirée s'est
prolongée en week end inattendu le
lendemain avec un goûter spectacle
proposé aux familles voilà c'est la fin
de ce set 8 journal belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]